the price is growing at retail,
the event
means
what is happening there in these other links, the
consumer is of little interest to the
consumer,
the same is true for
agricultural producers, we know
why this is happening, both in accordance with and in
connection with oil prices. Well, we understood what
would happen next.  This is not the first time
prices are rising, which means the company wants to
make the maximum profit by
exporting everything is clear,
they are doing their job, you and I, the
government must do the work in another way, we
will count on the fact that the
proposed measures will work
with the companies, we need to work more closely,
we have already  We talked to you
so that they, too, are responsible, it
is clear that the economics of the company is important to us, the
chicken that brings the Golden eggs is
understandable, we must take care of them
nevertheless